joining me now is desiree andrade mother
of
julian andrade and matt murphy former
senior
deputy district attorney desiree i am so
sorry for your loss i got the
opportunity to talk to you monday
your son was beaten left for dead he
fought for his life
and the d.a did what
absolutely nothing um in fact he's
making matters worse for me
i feel re-victimized all over again
having to relive moments that i thought
i would have justice for and
unfortunately now i'm fighting for my
son
all over again as i did in the very
beginning
yeah heartbreaking we talked for a
little bit of you talking
to his child to let them know that their
dad still loves them
after my interview that i did this
morning we got a statement from the d.a
and i want to read it for
you and get your reaction this is what
he said his spokesperson while a
minority of victims want the maximum
punishment imposed in their case
research shows these views are not
shared by the majority of survivors
of violent crimes as most survivors
don't find healing by putting another
person
in a cage our system of justice can't
continue to rely on policies
that create more victims tomorrow simply
because
a minority of victims want the maximum
punishment imposed
in their case what is your reaction to
that desiree
it makes me angry that is a very very
cold
statement it was the
minority of victims don't want this
i haven't met one victim's family yet
that wants their loved ones murders
murder out i don't understand that
statement
this is a human being we're talking
about this is someone's life
this is my son and for him to say
something like that
it makes me sick to my stomach that
that's who we have defending us victims
i truly do not believe he is a district
attorney he acts more like a public
defender in my eyes
and it really makes me upset a guy that
couldn't even pick up the phone
and call you releases a statement
like this matt how does a guy
like that get elected
well i think that uh the stars aligned
in the worst possible way in the last
election
we all witnessed it i mean i grew up in
l.a george gascon claims to be
progressive this is not
progressive this is regressive this
these policies take us right back to the
revolving door
that we had going in the 70s and 80s
that that resulted in the murders of
people like paulie klaus and marcy
nicholas
this is the kind of stuff that enacted
reforms like three strikes like the gun
enhancements
and and like victim rights in california
this is outrageous and i just heard that
for the first time just now that they're
saying a majority of the victims don't
support that
i was a prosecutor for 26 years i
attended parole hearings
for 17 of those as i worked in the
orange county homicide unit
that is there's no way that that is a
true statistic unless they did their own
poll of like
four people that are their ideological
ilk that is an outrageous thing to say
it is absolutely untrue victims who lose
loved ones due to violent crime
want justice for the people that were
taken away from them
and under current california law there
are ways to do that and george gascon
has
unilaterally decided he's not going to
impose gun enhancements gang
enhancements
strikes and the effect on my clients i
represent five of these families
one of whom is tonya owen who i just
heard on on the clip
her husband was a a sheriff's sergeant
who responded to a burglary
the person he encountered was a violent
felon with an extensive criminal history
a documented gang member who ambushed
him shot him once
disabled him walked over to him
and executed him shot him three times in
the face
and then another time in the badge
sending a message
right that guy because of george
gascon's policies
could be released as soon as eight years
from today
so if it takes us another year or two to
get to trial that's
literally less than six years in
california state prison
for that crime it is astounding george
gascon keeps coming out with these
with these statements that are
absolutely not true they've manipulated
statistics
it is outrageous what's happening and
the people of los angeles deserve better
i got to tell you i've been following
these cases desiree
the the guys that did this were in court
laughing
high-fiving with their defense attorney
then you got gascon
never prosecuted the case in his life
this is coming
not just to l.a but all across the
country
this show will stay on us desiree matt
thanks so much for being with us today
we will get justice thank you very much